wer hin
du hast jetzt schloss die gesellschaft
ja immer noch nicht aufgehängt und wo
sind die einkäufe hast du den sekt
nachgefüllt hillsboro ich doch das alles
denn auch dead block erst wenn ich es
sehe schätze kennen jetzt vertrauen
jedoch einfach mal sollte uns jetzt
einfach freuen dass alles gut gegangen
ist
lothar ist wieder wohlauf lotus wieder
da und wir sind diesen komischen
schocken los geworden und wir haben uns
alle gut und schön aber erst müssen wir
das ordentlich feiern wenn ich feiere
dann richtig also hopp hopp wo sind die
sektgläser
mädchen dem stück jud das hat sie
natürlich alles von dir gedacht steht
der guru schwester hier erst langsam
runter kommt wäre ihr leben perfekt
nicht verdienen
es könnte sich ganz zufällig ein glas
über den kochen lernen
und wer würde das eine anfängerin
überlegen kommt du mir mal nach hause
schnelleren schweren ziehen da ganz
wollte weil das in versteckter antrag
darf ich um eure aufmerksamkeit bitten
flott charlotte seitdem nicht ich kenne
es mein leben einfach runter es mag
meinen klamotten stil liegen aber vor
allem an einem bezaubernden wesen
es hat auf jeden fall auf mich abgefärbt
wir wurden lange genug zusammen um
diesen punkt als bestanden abzuhaken
wir bekommen ein kind wenn ich einfach
werden aber wir schaffen das und
deswegen möchte ich einen schritt weiter
gehen
er tue das nicht ich frage dich willst
du charlotte schäfer
willst du mit mir in eine größere
wohnung ziehen
ich bin bereit und nachdem die erste
rede schon eine enttäuschung war möchte
ich die gelegenheit kurz nutzen um
verzeihung zu bitten
vor allem die schon es tut mir so leid
dass richter dass ich technisch wollt
doch als chef muss ich alles im griff
haben und darf sich einfach blind
vertrauen
was hat dieser schmiede ist eigentlich
zu erwarten eine freiheitsstrafe bis zu
fünf jahre sind ihm sicher
und diese frau die bei euch gearbeitet
hat habe graf nachdem sie ihm auf die
schliche gekommen war wollte sie selbst
ein stück vom kuchen was sie hat ihn
erpresst sie war nur auf das geld aus
eiskalt lasst uns anstoßen schön dass
ihr alle gekommen seid auf einen schönen
abend auf dich zu tun